[Music]
[Applause]
let's make the smooth segway to chris
sims pro football talk live co-host have
you tried ayahuasca
i have not i mean um i did watch the
aubrey marcus podcast with aaron rodgers
i'm not opposed to it i'm not opposed to
maybe trying it at some point i don't
know i don't seem to have any like life
struggles in my brain or something i
need to overcome right now
to make me want to go there you know
that i you know habitually like to do
other things all the time anyways that
replace ayahuasca and help me you know
get into my own mind and self-reflect
and do that and it's you know good old
mary jane i like that
mary jane
the reefer
the reaper as my dad would call it yes
what did your dad say the first time he
knew you had smoked pot
uh he was not happy i mean i didn't
think this conversation was gonna go
that way he was not happy you know i
definitely went in the early years of
like uh maybe college and the nfl where
i would hide it from him and then i got
to that point where
you know maybe a year or two in the nfl
and i was like wait i'm a grown man like
i'm sick of trying to hide around the
corner from dad when i'm home visiting
him or whatever and that's when i you
know kind of broke the ice a little bit
and and he's been you know very good
that way for the most part and letting
me be me and you know it's just
something i've done i didn't do it a ton
through my nfl career dan honestly and
i'm gonna be totally transparent here
because you know i don't know any other
way i was in the drug program six out of
the eight years i played in the league i
always push the limit to oh they won't
test me right away or you know we got a
few weeks i'll i'll do one more night
and smoke a little more and i ended up
always in the drug program for those who
think like oh i want to say chris sims
he smoked too much pot that's why it
didn't work out no that's not right it's
it's i was actually pretty clean
throughout my the majority of my career
how often were they testing back then
not that much well listen i i how did
you get caught well i'm a little stupid
and a little daring i mean
we know that and uh anybody that knows
me i can push the limits a little bit so
you know you'd come back maybe and back
then the the it was so broad it could
happen anywhere from april to august so
you know it might be the first week of
april and we don't have to be maybe back
in the building to mid april late april
for otas and i'd go well they're not
going to get me right when i come back
and of course that would be the year
they'd get me right when i'd come back
and so i i made that mistake and once
you're in it you're in it for two years
so you know i'd get in it and then get
out of it finally and then you know play
with fire again and then i'd be back in
it and uh yeah that's kind of that's
kind of what i did but do you have
meetings where you get together
or like what
yeah it's
like you're on parole it's so you you
have to you and i know things have
changed now but you had to be available
for drug testing whenever they said they
would usually drug test you once per
week maybe twice per week and you hadn't
let them know where you were at all
times so if i traveled somewhere or
anything like that you had to call in
and be like hey i'm going to be at this
address you know i'm going to be here
for a few days and of course you know
when you did travel there was always
somebody that showed up so it was a pain
in the butt and yeah you did actually
have to see
a doctor where you know they could kind
of
help you out with your so-called
addiction and therapy that way which
that was probably the most annoying part
uh we'll make the awkward uh
yeah segway here
why why is deshaun watson why would the
browns have him start friday night
what's the rationale
yeah well i think the rationale is it's
a guy that hasn't played a whole you
know hasn't played in a long time and
and you know i'm not telling you
anything you don't know you're a huge
sports fan and watch it all i don't care
who you are when you've gone this long
long of a period of time without playing
football especially the quarterback
position which really can't be emulated
in practice you know the crowd the
pressure of the moment wait i'm actually
going to get really hit now so i got to
make decisions and some guys trying to
tear my head off you know that's it's
not like riding a bike you know we've
seen hey the greatest quarterbacks ever
peyton manning be hurt and come back and
have a little bit of a slow start think
about tom brady after he hurt his knee
in 2008 in 2009 he wasn't you know the
tom brady we remembered before the
injury especially not right away so i
would think that's the big thing they
just want to get him out there and get
some live action because they've
invested a lot of money into them but i
got to get jacoby brissette ready
because he's going to be the starter for
at least the first six games i i hear
you no doubt i think it'll be a lot more
than six games really when it's all said
and done but yeah that's that's where i
do feel for kevin stefanski and the
coaching staff there in cleveland i
don't think they were the ones raising
their hands begging for this situation
you know to happen they're kind of stuck
in a tough situation they're trying to
do the best with it but yeah they have
to balance uh i think especially hey
early on preseason game one i understand
that desean watson start maybe as we get
to preseason game number three and if
watson isn't suspended by that time
that's when you see jacoby per set start
and they go okay now we're gonna get we
gotta get into season mode here deshawn
we'll get you some reps here at some
point during the game or whatever else
but i don't think they'll change their
thought as we get deeper into training
camp or deeper into preseason but dan i
don't think there's i still don't think
he's going to play tomorrow night i i
think that ruling's going to come down
here in the next 24 hours i i
i would be shocked i don't think the nfl
and the powers do you think the
commissioner is saying to this guy the
former attorney general
i don't want him on tv i don't want him
out there i need your ruling by you know
tomorrow afternoon
no i i don't know if he's flat out
saying it like that but i wouldn't be
surprised if they you know he's gotten
some context clues about what they would
like you know we all know how sensitive
they are and rightly so about protecting
the shield this is a hot button topic
you know and certainly desean did not
act appropriately here for a long long
time and i don't think the nfl wants
this to dominate the first real
week one of preseason where all we're
going to talk about is desean watson if
he plays on friday night and he's going
to be on every screens associated with
the shield and i would got to think that
you know goodell and some of the other
powerful owners don't want that look in
the league we're talking to chris sims
pro football talk live co-host with mike
florio you can see it preceding this
show on peacock and of course former nfl
quarterback and contributor to football
night in america you played for the
patriots help me understand it felt like
the media became obsessed with the
struggles of mack jones the last couple
of days
and i thought what am i missing here
does it matter that and
is the offense different this year than
it was last year when they won he won 10
games
i don't think it would be different
especially not at this point you know
and i know that crew up there and you
know of course played for
josh mcdaniels in denver a little bit
they they're the type that goes like hey
wait here's 10 plays and we're going to
master these 10 plays before we move on
they're not going to get too deep into
the playbook or you know game planning
different schemes or anything like that
so the defense knows what's happening
yes the defense knows what's happening
we know it's a very good talented
defense there for sure and then the
other thing that i think this is where i
don't hit the panic button quite yet and
the situation's weird and it's different
you know as far as the rest of the nfl
we'd probably be a lot more critical if
it was anybody else besides the new
england patriots but in bill belichick
we trust yeah but we wouldn't know about
this if it was another team you might
you're right we might not you're right
we might not i mean but but either way
the fact that they don't have an
offensive coordinator title it is
strange but but this is where i think
they're different than a lot of teams
you know they do not script for success
in practice you know there's a lot of
teams that hey that they're figuring out
the practice schedule and they go the
offensive coordinator hey hey we're
going to run this play so can you run
this defense right and and it's all
about gaining confidence and getting
rhythm and there's a lot of that that
goes on in nfl camps new england doesn't
care they don't do it that way they are
like hey you figure out the plays you're
going to run we'll figure out what we're
going to do over here and it might look
ugly but that's the way football is
we're not going to like oh make it the
perfect coverage for your perfect little
play so you guys feel good and i can
remember being there and with tom brady
and seeing practices with him where
it wasn't you know an
absolute precision show because they
make things tough they make things game
like and i think that's why they're
usually better in games and maybe
sometimes it can look and practice but
yeah they're
when i was with john gruden and other
places there was constantly script for
success because the defense can learn
how to play anything against anything so
you always go well hey they're gonna
have to defend this play at some point
in this coverage but you know yes we had
a lot of times where the first eight
plays were hey this play we're gonna run
it against the exact coverage we want
and hopefully we can execute it and then
like i said new england doesn't quite
roll like that i hope i explain that
clearly enough no i get it i understand
that you know
it's not pretty but it's not meant to
look pretty it's meant to be like this
could be what we faced not exactly yeah
the defense we didn't expect now what do
we do with something exactly we're gonna
coach off that and we're gonna adjust
and okay when that happens to us in a
game in week one what are we gonna do
there and that's where they're they're
special that way in my opinion you have
certain teams certain coaches
that want to win every preseason game
you know the ravens i think what 20
games in a row like you don't
accidentally win 20 consecutive
preseason games
how tell me the difference in philosophy
with coaches did you have coaches who
did want to win and coaches who didn't
really care about the bottom line
yes definitely i mean like um and it
depended on the year there was years i
feel like with you know maybe john
gruden and tampa where
he might game plan you know a few plays
for the preseason to you know stoke a
little confidence and get some rhythm
going in the offense and the team that
way there there might be years like that
and then there might have been another
year where hey we feel like we're pretty
good and we're just going to run our
core plays and you know do what we got
to do there so it does it depends and
then of course it depends on who you're
playing too because sometimes you play a
team where you know hey we're going to
keep it vanilla this week and then you
get out in the preseason game and you go
oh crap they're doing some stuff that we
haven't really you know talked about in
practice or figured out quite yet and
you got to readjust so that's where the
preseason sometimes could be you know
hard to dictate or tell you know where
teams are at at times and that's
certainly you know a part of it no doubt
always good to talk to you chris thanks
for joining us and uh all right buddy
thanks
you the man tell the guys i said hi
that's chris sims pro football talk live
co-host with mike florio